our next guest is a former monk who is
now teaching millions of people how to
improve their overall wellness jay
shetty is his name he's a best-selling
author and host of the very popular
health and wellness podcast called on
purpose his philosophies have grabbed
the attention of celebrities that you
know will smith is a big fan i know
oprah's a big big big fan lisa keys and
before all that he was a monk for three
years in india now shetty is teaming up
with the meditation app calm he just
announced that he will be the new chief
purpose officer
perfect for uj and he will lead daily
meditations jay shetty joins us we're
happy to say in the studio and today is
day one that we can all get the daily
jay today is day one it's an exciting
day thank you i'm so glad you're here
it's it's perfect that you're here today
you said it's seven minutes and i'm
curious about how you came up with seven
minutes because meditation is still very
intimidating for a lot of people they
think i can't quiet my mind i don't have
the time and you say what to all of that
so when i started researching our daily
activities i found a lot of them can be
done in seven minutes so whether it's
making our bed whether it's
sorting our laundry doing the dishes and
so i thought how amazing would it be if
we could create a meditation that you
didn't have to make time for but we
could actually bring meditation into
your life so you could do it while
you're doing those activities really
because you always think you have to be
in a quiet place dim the lights you
saying no no you don't have to change
what you're wearing you don't have to
sit on a yoga mat you don't have to dim
the lights you can do it in your daily
activity i want this to be something
that anyone can do anywhere anytime how
how do you weave it into your daily
activity well this is the beautiful
thing about meditation is that i think
we have a misconception that it means
you have to be quiet you have to be
still but so you could do it while
folding laundry you're saying yes
yeah because you could join in
practice breathing you can actually join
in hear the story that will transform
your mindset and then a takeaway that
you can actually apply while you're
doing the laundry so now you have this
practice that's actually becoming a
lifestyle rather than a tool that you
feel is actually taking time out of your
day yeah we should say it's a guided
meditation
and we get the app and so you will guide
us every day and every day it will be
something different every day every
single day there'll be seven minutes
i'll be guiding you through be a story
and insight some breathing and this
combination really leads to a beautiful
experience to start or end your day yeah
it's going to help improve wellness yes
but speaking of that you've talked about
improving wellness by taking small steps
what are some of those small steps one
of the small steps that we can all take
is checking our thoughts now studies
show that we have 12 to 60 000 thoughts
per day and 60 to 80 of those are
negative and repetitive so one of my
favorite things that we can do is we can
actually pair things with an old habit
so anything that you already do every
day like brushing your teeth right add
something positive to that anything like
you're doing like washing your clothes
add something positive to that and
another thing you can do is by starting
one thing at a time i think sometimes we
take on a million things to change in
our lives let's just start with one this
year now that's powerful that you said
that because your thoughts they become
action and then action becomes who you
are who you are becomes how you feel um
what advice do you give to somebody who
might have negative thoughts um and they
don't know what to do with them in the
moment yeah so i have a three-step
formula for that it's called spot stop
swap and i know in my accent it sounds
kind of weird so i'll ask you to repeat
it stop swap that was great
that was brilliant so the first thing
you want to do is you want to spot when
you have those thoughts are you on a
particular instagram profile is it when
you're with a particular group of people
spot when do you have those thoughts
become really hyper aware the second
thing is stop and reflect before you're
about to be in that space before you're
about to follow that person or be in
that group of people ask yourself wait
how can i go into this with better
energy am i aware of what i'm about to
experience and finally swap you can
actually replace it with something i
think often we try and stop ourselves
from doing things right but we actually
have to substitute them for something
better something more interesting i like
that too it's a monday some people
already need a reset on the week uh can
you guide us through an exercise to kind
of reset where we are mentally at the
moment i would absolutely love to do
that thank you for the opportunity so
i'm going to ask us all how long does it
take this is going to take
15 seconds
the first thing i'm going to ask you do
and i want everyone to join in at home
is look around we're in the studio and
focus on five things just five things
you can see in the studio in the studio
five things
[Music]
and when you've found those you can
close your eyes
[Music]
take in a deep breath
and now what are four things you can
touch
might be the chair
the jacket you're wearing or the dress
your pants just notice the different
textures
and now what are three things you can
hear
maybe some white noise
maybe a sound outside your window
taking another deep breath
what are two things you can smell
maybe a fragrance or a scent
maybe some flowers of the wind
and what's one thing you can taste
maybe your breakfast lunch or toothpaste
when you open your eyes take a deep
breath
and experience the presence of this
moment
so that's that's known as the 54321
method in psychology and for presence
training and it allows us to truly be
where our feet are and we could all do
that yeah that was beautiful that was
your cologne that was effective
i love it jay
that was effective i have to say i had
my doubts and at first i thought i was
gonna hit hit in the face with a pie
when i closed my eyes
no but seven minutes every day every
single day only on calm jay shetty thank
you very much thank you so much